that's what love it you know what love
is you know what if I get to still love
down into one moment this right here
will be the moment of love right here
[ __ ] move look at the other side of
the bed look at that area
look at that stuff gazing into my
[ __ ] eyes for two seconds and look at
the other area and then look at this
zero area I've got over here look at
that vast area they shot Mad Max on the
other Sun you Tom Hardy's over there on
the front of a vehicle like and I'm over
here with my leg and my dick flopped off
the bed explain explain why my dick is
fluffed off the bed
they shot Mad Max and Dances with Wolves
on the other side of you Kevin Costner
is over there with a water buffalo
just like show money Pathan cahuachi
he's saying that
and every time you turn you take the
covers you know you do that chef every
time you turn you take it you take it
and I'm over there and you're sleeping
but you're dreaming [ __ ] him he doesn't
deserve them and you take it and you
take it and you take it and you do a
billion revolutions a night you take it
you take it and then when you come back
you leave it you take it and then leave
it over there you take it and then leave
it you're like a shitty [ __ ]
typewriter you're a typewriting ass
[ __ ] and I'm over here with no covers
of frigid freezing cold dick and my
mouth is bleeding thank you [ __ ]